or shop he was the runner-up for the
Democratic presidential nomination in
2016 you might remember the senator from
Vermont Bernie Sanders
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you are more popular than stormy Daniels
lawyer sounds like they want you to run
again
but there's an election before 2020 and
a stirrers know you've been going around
saying and I couldn't agree more it's
the most important election ever I'm
gonna ask you why but first a little
bone to pick with you politicians I have
been hearing since I was 18 years old
every election is the most important
election in your life so you all cried
wolf on this one and a lot of people are
not going to believe it but this one
really is the most important please tell
us why it's the most important because
we have a president who is a
pathological liar we have a president
who has strong authoritarian tendencies
who wants to do every day undermine
American democracy you know and in my
state and all over this country you have
many women who have fought and died to
defend American democracy and this guy
looks all over the world and it kind of
likes all of these authoritarian leaders
he attacks the meteor every day trying
to make it harder for them to be
critical of him and we have a president
who is a billionaire himself was
surrounded himself with billionaires who
gave huge tax breaks to the wealthiest
people in this country and then brings
forth a budget that would cut Medicaid
by a trillion dollars Medicare by 500
billion dollars cut nutrition programs
for hungry kids cut Social Security
disability a president who told the
American people that he was gonna
provide health care to everybody
remember that bill cheaper and better
cheaper and better and then he supports
legislation to throw 32 million people
off of the health care that they had so
when does that sink in with his people
what because gas prices are growing up
because he shelled the Iran deal people
do not have as good health care and some
have been thrown off he's gonna lose
jobs because of this tariff trade war
he's starting when does the cult of
personality wear away in favor of wait
you're actually hurting me
but we need to do
is a couple of things frankly from a
political point of view it is not good
enough to simply attack Trump every
single day what we need to do is bring
forth an agenda that working people all
over this country are gonna respond to
and let me be very clear and I've said
it before in 2016 it's not the Trump one
it's the Democrats lost and for too long
the Democratic Party the Democratic
Party has been dominated by wealthy
campaign contributors they got to open
the door to people who work with their
hands people who take showers at the end
of the day not at the beginning of the
day young people and we have a
generation out there of some of the
brightest most decent young people in
the history of this country beautiful
young people and what we have to do bill
let's not forget this four years ago in
2014 we had the lowest voter turnout for
a midterm election since World War two
37% of the people voted if we increase
that voter turnout by 50% Democrats win
the house win the Senate and that's what
we
right so you mentioned the Democrats
lost last time but your agenda one you
may not have won the nomination right
but you talked about an agenda they're
all behind that now let me Medicare for
all
yep you know all the people who are
running for president we can't know who
they are and a income inequality all
those issues right but an agenda is not
a message they are different Trump is
better at messaging they don't his
voters don't seem to care about an
agenda or anything except build a wall
lock her up
what's the Democrats message if you had
to boil it down to something that would
fit on a hat which is about all people
can take in at this career
what is the Democratic Messimer chronic
message is that we need a government
that represents working families not
billionaires an agenda an agenda that
says that health care is a right not a
privilege an agenda that speaks to the
young people and says that we should
make public colleges and universities
tuition-free and lowest student debt but
Trump has shown that the American people
they elected him I I understand he
didn't win the popular vote but he got a
lot of votes and so they and his
popularity rating keeps going up not
down yeah it's it's almost in the range
of like a normal president which is
really scary because he certainly is not
that so they obviously don't care about
so many things they used to care about
like decorum or policy or democracy or
freedom of the press so in this new
arena and he's a he is brilliant at
controlling the debate and controlling
airtime what does it Democrat have to do
to compete on this news is a news day
that's a fair point and the air time
issue is very difficult young people's
are we're wired the Democrats talking
about distance well you know what in
many cases Democrats aw but were
overwhelmed with Trump's tweets and the
absurdity of the day
so I think what Democrats have got to do
basically is go into Trump country and
talk to people who are now living in
desperation you know the truth of the
matter is one of the reasons in my view
that Trump won is that he sensed that
there were millions of people in this
country who were ignored by the
political establishment they ignored by
the elite they're working longer hours
for lower wages they're scared to death
about the future facing their children
and he said any light I hear you
our job is not to lie to have the guts
to deal with the serious issues that
they face and to take on the people who
are power in this country and let me
just mention if I might bill I'm here in
LA today tomorrow you know what I'll be
I'll be with workers in Disneyland who
are working for one of the largest
corporations in America that gave their
CEO a four hundred million dollar
compensation package but I paying their
workers starvation wages and I'm gonna
stand with those workers getting decent
wages and forming a union
and later in the day we're gonna be
dealing and working with folks for black
lives matter addressing a broken
criminal justice system which more and
more people understand needs fundamental
reform you sound like you're busy I'll
let you go with one more question you
have a big agenda and by the way you
don't look any different than the last
time you ran so if if you don't run
don't do it just because of age don't
let them intimidate you about that but
the Democratic Party is traditionally
pulled apart by this battle that we saw
in 2016 between the left and the center
Hillary Clinton's a centrist you ran a
whole different kind of campaign how do
we unite them because that's the path to
victory is is to is the United and the
last one to do it was was Obama who was
really more of a centrist but people saw
him as a leftist because they wanted to
I think we are coming together around a
progressive agenda as you indicated
Medicare for all raising the minimum
wage climate change etc and I think
frankly that at the end of the primary
season every person in the Democratic
community will understand that we have
infinitely more in common then our
dispar differences or and that we got a
unites we got to bring our community
together to take on the most outrageous
president in the history of this country
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]